[موسيقى]
[تصفيق
] علاقتي بكيرا كانت شغفًا للغاية ،
لقد جئت إلى هنا عندما كان عمري 18 عامًا ،
لكنني أردت فقط أن أصبح
راقصة باليه محترفة لم أتخيل نفسي أبدًا
كراقصة رئيسية كنت في العاشرة من عمري عندما
أنشأوا الأوبرا  حلم كبير
بالنسبة لي للرقص على هذه المرحلة ، لقد كنت
راقصًا رئيسيًا في القاهرة
/ المنزل لمدة 22 عامًا ، لقد وقعت في حب
الرقص هنا ،
نحن في سيارة اقتربنا من هذا هو
المكان الذي نقضي فيه معظم يومنا اليوم
نحن ذاهبون  لإجراء بروفة
لرقصة الباليه الجديدة لهذا الموسم ، إنه
الحمام الأول ، أنا في الواقع متوترة للغاية
لأنها واحدة من
أقوى النساء الرائدات في العالم ويرغبن حقًا
في القيام بذلك بالطريقة الصحيحة في هذا
الإنتاج ولعب Caesar I'm
متحمس جدًا لأنني أحب القصص التي
تجعلها لنا للمصريين ، إنها مرهقة للغاية
لأنك لا تشعر بالرضا عن نفسك أبدًا ،
فأنت تعتقد دائمًا أنه يمكنك القيام
بأشياء
أفضل ، رقصت مع أنيا مثل 12 عامًا ،
إنها أفضل 12 عامًا في حياتي ليس
لأنها  الزوجة ليس لأنها
شريكتي ولكن لأنها تشعر بما
تفعله وهذا الشعور ينتقل إلى
الناس
[موسيقى]
عندما تخطو على خشبة المسرح ،
يجب أن تكون قبعتك باردة ولكن قلبك يجب أن يكون
دافئًا في كل مرة إنه شيء جميل
ومدهش إنه مجرد  آخر
وهو بداية الإنتاج ، أقوم
بعمل قيصر وهو يحتضر في
نهاية المكدس عندما ينتهي
ويستمتع الناس به ويمكنك تصديق
التصفيق أحبه كثيرًا أحب هذا وأنا
أحب الرقص وحياتنا  هو
[تصفيق]